The joe rogan experience.
[inaudible]
that was a beautiful day.
Beautiful Day to be back in California.
How about this weather we'll live in like doctors out here.
It doesn't get on nicer than this.
We got leopards behind.
This is getting nicer.
It's perfect weather.
Really appreciate California when he goes somewhere else.
I just wish there weren't so many fucking people,
but I guess that's just part of the
most important thing.
Why we love all you.
People will always say,
well we got good stuff by us.
Still bid on that dog.
That's number one.
Oh g dirty 3.94% tested a February.
That means what?
That next doc comes up as September.
People's heads will be blown up like gene Simmons in that weren't fucking movie
is that it just blew the fuck up man.
That was with Tom Selleck?
No,
that was with the guy that's German.
That was it.
Oh Rutger.
Hauer okay.
How I want it dead or alive.
Well he goes up to him and he goes give 200,000 to whatever it separately the
bonus and he goes to Tony.
It looks back at Gene Simmons and he touches his face.
Oh,
sleep polls the clip out of his mouth and he looks at the other guys.
He goes,
fuck the boldest and it blows.
It just blows his fucking head off.
That's just going to be happening in September.
So Gene Simmons just got arrested or charged with some sort of sexual assault.
Really?
Yeah.
Some they complain.
He says he grabbed her on her shit.
He slept with 9,000 would you think it needs to fucking some fat?
Make up the thank you know you want to keep the party rolling man.
You know,
sometimes everybody wants to go home and they want the party to be over.
You want to it love Jean said Miss,
I love Gene Simmons to put that fucker.
We've has got to go.
God,
it's got to go get really bad.
Yeah.
It could see us like old spiderweb,
the spy,
the worst the most is they just painted it black and put it on his fucking head.
All rockers,
man.
Nobody ever did that before.
Nobody ever got old in front of us.
You know,
nobody was ever young.
And then we made it all the way to being like an old dude,
still doing the same act.
You know,
that never really happened before.
Right.
I mean,
I guess it sort of happened in the forties and fifties and shit,
but a lot of those dudes just died.
You know,
like Elvis died and buddy Holly died and you know,
I mean,
not that many dudes just really,
I started went a jail.
Yeah,
that's my boy.
Right.
John Lennon got shot at the Beatles,
broke up.
George Harrison's dead.
You know,
it is not,
not a whole lot of dudes that went all the way from the 70s all the way to
today,
rocking out,
doing the same thing.
You know,
who had the rolling stones?
Man,
they're still fucking pulling it off.
Right.
Books
still pulling it up,
still going to Brazil and banging tens is it,
didn't he just like have a baby or something?
Didn't Mick Jagger?
So he's got dark team or babies and all little sports.
Vega.
That motherfucker Bro.
When he tricked this old wife.
Yeah.
Later in another country.
And she's like,
what?
I go,
he's like,
bitch,
check the fine print
though.
Can I paid that guy $8 you know what I'm saying?
That shit don't work.
Exactly.
Legit.
Can you do that?
I don't know.
I don't think that holds up.
Jacket did it?
He still asked to pray.
Listen Bro.
Mick Jagger's with her best book and spending my time.
I was living in boulder.
They played Bolga at the stadium.
It was like a three hour delay and like a bunch of weight.
I was talking to some people don't like dog.
Mick Jagger showed up and seen that the tickets were still having to be behind
the stage.
He didn't give a fuck if they couldn't see him.
I ain't going on stage.
You saw those tickets really?
He made them sell apples.
Talking tickets with,
couldn't even see this to give it to them for half price.
You got to get some.
Wow.
He's a fucking businessman.
Fuck yeah.
Three hours late for you,
so I don't care.
I have nothing to do.
How do you know that it was him?
It was his decision then the buckets.
He was the businessman.
He was the last and a real boy he could spend.
You have a mechanic hat on?
Is it from the new movie?
Yeah,
but I'm supporting the old one out of respect,
the old movies,
you know what I'm saying?
The bumpers or even I wouldn't fucking watch them with my eyeballs of his
planning lawyer was watching his plane.
He was,
it was okay.
It wasn't bad.
I liked that dude.
I like him too,
but he ain't going to Charles Bronson.
You can't.
Oh yeah,
that's a problem,
man.
When you can't do a movie,
I mean you play a great assassin,
but when you called the mechanic and then you have sort of the same sort of plot
twist,
and then he takes out a protege and it didn't make sense that he took out a
protege in this movie in Charles Bronson's movie.
Charles Bronson seems like legitimately troubled.
This guy seemed like all of a sudden he's breaking his own rules and he's
hanging out with this dude just cause he killed his dad without fuck.
And it didn't.
It didn't,
I didn't buy it in a Charles Bronson movie.
I bought troubled.
It was a bad mother fucker dude.
When he was doing hard times,
he was like 50,
you know that when he did that fucking cage fighting movie,
you remember that Shit.
Fuck yeah.
He was like 50 years old and we did that movie and we get the fuck out of here.
Thanks.
You do the podcast.
Hello
Bam.
Podcasts over ours fear you.
How you and Brian had a little hissy fit.
How do you think you guys recovered from that?
It's not a his foot.
No.
Was it mostly it was just the point was that um,
you need to trust the people.
They do stuff around.
So no matter what,
even if people don't know what we're talking about,
they had a psychedelic adventure to psychedelics.
You're doing.
Psychedelics could be in a place where you feel comfortable like podcast six
comedian comedy took me a while.
The being smoking at the UFC and then doing edibles at Eoc to them.
Then move up to feeling comfortable enough in this environment.
I can do acid.
I wouldn't do that.
My first trips.
Do you think you were trying to get new ones?
You got to do it July 1st.
July 2nd.
Here's my plan.
Announced right here.
Okay.
I'm having a scavenger hunt for edibles.
Um,
I don't know how to do it yet.
Yes,
I guess I know how I'm gonna do it,
but there's gotta be some way that if you find a phrase and come find me and say
whatever the phrase that is like president of the amazing,
whatever it is,
I'll be like,
boom.
There you go.
Have a good trip.
I think you are at early on.
Grossly underestimating the power of the podcast.
You're fucked right now.
You're fucked man.
Alright.
Scavenge Hunt and officers of the law would be able to easily do that.
Yeah,
you're ready?
Hey,
I am.
The secret word is I'm a cop and you're under arrest.
Okay,
this guy's crazy.
He's a rebel.
He's a practical,
regular hunter.
S Thompson.
Nope.
There's no,
if you're a captain,
[inaudible] was just fucking,
it's fine.
Nobody's getting hurt on this one.
They might get hurt,
but if you're one of those guys,
we're going to figure out a way to do a scavenger hunt.
And if I leave clues tape,
don't be a Douche or fucking rips them off because I have to think that though
too.
Right,
right.
They'll be like,
no one else has got it.
Yeah.
Do you can't do that.
You can't cheat because maybe you should have some kind of a rule.
Yeah.
You've got to have a way to get it there on the couch.
Stop.
Yeah.
Well we'll make like go to this concession stand.
The third line where say the safest way to do it is to hide the stuff somewhere
to say that you're gonna put it like go to some like shirt and put it like under
the skull tee shirt and then Twitter at Twitter where you put it and then leave.
Oh,
oh.
I thought it was like I didn't have it that way where they could actually just
find the thing I had like one is caption for clue.
This will take you there.
That clue takes you there and then that gives you the price and then price is
kind of complicated for stoners,
so just where it is,
you just decide to take brownies and insert them in place.
It's like there's the gas cowboy boots on the face of the earth during this
store.
Yes.
Something like that.
Reach inside if you find those.
Yeah,
and then come my,
I had my mind that they would come up to me and I can see what they were and
just watch him do it.
But you know what?
Fuck it.
Just tell me who you are.
You can always say,
uh Huh.
I've heard it.
If you go over to that store,
do you find the gaze boots in the world and inside that boot is a Brownie.
Could just be a rumor.
Can you say that?
That way you absolve yourself with any criminal?
Not just,
that's the word.
The word on the street is,
is a Brownie in those gay cowboy boots.
It's like a quick,
you know,
whatever.
Something like that.
I see a purple fucking plan.
All right.
It's all right.
We've got a plan folks.
July 2nd shit's going down.
Talking monkey is not involved with the actual purchase or
very good.
Yeah.
Okay.
Another beautiful day in southern California and I'm with my pal Duncan
Trussell.
Hi.
We just got done doing the podcast and you,
he introduced me to the whitest teeth.
Do you know the pledge of allegiance?
I pledge allegiance.
Where as kids,
you know,
check it out.
Fucking genius versus shove this into that,
into the podcast where we get sued.
That probably get in trouble for it.
It's so good that I think the widest kids,
you know,
we'll probably be dead within a week daily.
I think their,
their plane's going down.
I
don't think he was.
You're on a plane with the widest kids,
you know,
get off.
Yeah,
Freak out.
Have a freak out.
It's going to jail.
It's worth going to jail.
Stay alive.
It's brilliant though.
The pledge of allegiance things fucking amazing.
It's perfect.
It's like talking about how creepy it is.
How many kids recite?
I don't want to tell you anymore.
It's just,
it's all,
it's good to check it out too.
We always go to some crazy deep ass fucking weird place when we do the task.
But you don't do that that much on your lavender hour,
right?
Well,
it,
yeah,
it did.
Not as much as we get on this.
I don't do this that much anywhere I these kinds of conversations like I'll have
them with Natasha.
We're not recording stuff,
but I don't have them all the time.
I'd probably be in a hospital.
These are the kind of car I'd be pushing a cart down Laci in it goes screaming.
Yes.
Screening.
What is it about this podcast that brings it out in you and makes you have these
crazy conversations with us?
Oh,
it's probably a combination of the super strong marijuana and you put a black
gets in the coconut water.
It's nature coming together.
Some sort of a weird concocted combination of chemicals.
Events.
Yeah.
Maybe it's your tattoo.
Maybe like a,
you get sucked in the summer too,
but it's great if it was good.
Good.
All sleeved up.
If you can take the pain,
take the pain.
Man,
I just stopped.
I don't know what the fuck.
I don't know.
What to put on my arm.
I can't make the decision.
I changed my mind so much.
Nikola Tesla with a a bottle in his hand.
That's a great Tequila drinking.
That's a great idea,
man.
But the PR,
this is why I don't want to tattoo.
Here's why I don't want to tattoo.
Why LIGO?
Tesla fucking that pigeon that he loved so much because you got to explain it to
everybody.
It'd be creates a talking point for strangers.
Well,
if you ever break up with your check,
you've got them.
You got something sort of slapped that thing down at the bar and the girls would
go,
what is that?
Fucking a pigeon.
Yeah.
Well you don't know the Nikola Tesla story,
honey.
Yeah,
that's exactly how I operated.
I happened to have a DVD in my fanny pack.
It's amazing.
I did a thing called drunk history and HPL.
You might've seen it here.
Check.
Can we,
can we put that on a podcast?
That drunk history.
Can we show people that?
Well,
it's on youtube.
I don't know if you can.
It's not mine,
so it's probably not.
It's HBO.
We just stick it in here and put it on Youtube.
It's on youtube.
If you embed a youtube link,
just youtube drunk history,
Tesla,
but it's not
the beginning.
They got their fingers in your now it's true.
It's true.
Once we started getting on serious,
bringing in lawyers,
but I think lawyers will scare them with our plans to,
to move this into some sort of a cable television format.
I don't think we're going to lose much as long as we continue to do it exactly
the same way.
I think it will be a little bit more complicated cause it'll be on a set
instead of in my house.
But look,
if it sucks,
we'll just start doing them in my house too.
Well yeah,
do both.
Yeah.
They can't stop me.
If you get out of your one,
the time TV and one that's uncensored,
we could do that.
We can do it one day a week on television and the other days a week do it here.
If it is,
we do that.
The key is to just keep doing it the key or now seems to be,
uh,
when you,
your approach,
all the social networking stuff and you look at like how it's helped people in
the past,
like Dane Cook and he's the master of it.
Obviously when you look how it helped him,
said it was a slow build and slowly built to the point where it sort of,
you know,
took on a life of its own.
I think the model you should follow for you though is not Dane Cook.
I think it's David Koresh.
It was a slow bells for him too,
but you're going to have a terrible ATF agents,
Mormon.
You're fucking studio.
Once they know where it is.
Why,
what are we doing wrong?
I don't know yet.
What are we doing wrong?
He starts off with some ideas,
man.
Good.
I'm not looking to overthrow the government.
I'm looking at to get high and we'd go to movies.
I want to get high,
go to movies and overthrow the government.
I don't think work man.
I don't measure of running the government.
I loved it.
I love this country.
I left the government,
the United States of America.
I left police officers that will cover it and I don't want to do anything mean
to you guys.
I love you.
Please don't kill me.
That said,
that's the end of this video blog,
which is three in one week.
I hope you liked it.
Oh,
sure.
We'll mix it up.
Al Magical.
It's just on the podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen.
That was great.
I have known Al for at least 10 years,
right?
Yeah.
I'd be more 10 years.
Years.
Yeah.
Did we smoke pot in your friend's apartment?
It was my apartment was your apartment?
No,
we watch old.
That's right.
We did.
We watch over from [inaudible].
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Thanks.
I'm fascinated by Oprah,
which I am certain extent,
but it's been going on for that log
by Oprah.
Fascinating.
No,
we sat there going like this.
I remember just eating salad,
right?
Just looking at it like,
yeah,
look,
yeah.
This was the non assertive.
Oprah didn't have control of her own destiny.
This was the Oprah that really was just like interviewing like KKK members and
stuff and people would sit and folding chairs.
It was like old school Oprah where you're a huge color purple fan or no,
and everyone wants that movie.
That dude,
that Gif of her taking the piss and colored Provo.
We just did it over and over again.
So just to take it over a p,
I would,
um,
I would love to meet that Steadman character and hang out with him and find out
what's going on with that.
Right.
Insane.
What does she do for companionship?
She's got a beard.
Okay.
Nick's got a girlfriend.
Her name,
that girlfriend that Gail chick has her boyfriend or her girlfriends.
Yeah.
Thanks.
So a lot of people do.
I pick it.
And then that other dude that Steadman guys like hanging around,
who knows who gives a fuck?
It would be sad.
Oh,
well maybe that would be cool,
man.
What is she came out?
What if she retired or shout and then came out?
That would be kind of funny.
I think she's,
I think she's gay.
It doesn't matter.
It's not gonna ruin your career.
No,
no,
no.
I think she's fantastic.
I do too.
I love Oprah.
But there was always this notion for it.
I do love Oprah.
I think Oprah is a very positive man.
I listened to her,
uh,
her,
her show,
she's positive.
Look man,
like I said,
not everyone's out magical.
Not everyone's view,
not everyone's made.
It's different people that have different tastes.
I like watching professional pool.
You know,
most people think is probably one of the most boring fucking things in the world
to watch.
I'll never say what's,
you know,
when anybody shouldn't,
shouldn't like,
but I recognize that for people like Oprah,
for women that are like,
have like a huge,
and you know,
and like interest and like,
she's fucking fantastic guru.
Yeah.
She's a,
she's majestic man.
She,
those,
those women,
they found a voice.
They found someone who just really,
not just relates to them,
but elevates them and gives them something where they feel like they belong to.
There's gotta be a big void.
Who's gonna fill it?
Magical.
Why don't you put on a dress and maybe you can get an actual grout there.
Let's do it together.
You don't have to put on a dress that's do it will wear dresses and we'll
pretend we're women and we won't even address it.
Give her breastfeed.
Cut that out because it's not funny.
Mini van men.com al Magical Mazda.
Ronnie and who else is on?
Chris Spencer and Chris Spencer.
Beautiful.
He can't,
he can't miss it.
Get that shit.
If right now it's on just minivan men.com eventually it'll go on iTunes and you
could fall out on Twitter.
Owl managerial,
That's my buddy.
Well,
my kids,
I got European journalists to strangle
the fucking,
the Italian study ratio down.
You sitting there scene.
They're just like,
oh God.
It really write things down.
Who's the what country is the biggest problem?
Japan's the office.
Do you have an interpreter and shit like that that could you tell me was three.
I'm like,
there's no one's really like,
I'm just stuck with you.
They're like,
all right.
All right,
cool.
Are you videoing
keeping egg roll?
Yes.
Let's show everybody what's up,
Mr. Huge.
What's that guy's name?
Leaner that got busted.
Tony Wiener.
Yeah.
What does he do?
Is he a senator?
What does the center,
something like that.
Yeah,
he has like 8,000 followers on Twitter.
And at what points does anybody ever actually landed a girl by sitting in the
corner of,
that's for sure.
That's why they're doing so I met her,
I think it's about,
you got same question in the room,
but everyone goes,
no,
no.
And he goes,
I did.
And then
it's all about swinging at a lot of pitches.
I think
it doesn't matter if you strike out you a swing.
I got a buddy of mine,
he would fuck anything.
And for every disgusting girl he would land.
He would land a super hockey.
Yeah.
Cause he just didn't give a shit.
He's like,
look,
there's a whole,
yeah,
I have a buddy who is not an attractive guy,
but he will hit on anything.
And he goes,
hey,
you never know.
You never know.
There's no answers.
That confidence that they're like,
all right.
And then there's the guy,
he just runs his mouth,
but something happens to them as they get older,
they start getting crazy
sorrow,
like trying to lock off objection that they're getting constant objecting to go
like 90% ejection temperature,
10% acceptance.
So 90% you get the fuck away.
The guys who just keep the fucking fine.
All right.
Shut up.
You very much enjoy Vancouver nugget when he'd be ladies.
Nice meeting you.
If I did it today,
if I did it today,
it'd be different too because I'm a different person.
I'm a different person.
I was just four or five years ago,
you know,
I think I'd be better at it today.
I got him,
uh,
I have more patients,
you know,
especially um,
fear factor.
Yeah.
If I started doing fear factor again,
I have,
I have more patience with people I think than I ever had back then,
which is ridiculous when you think about it.
Yeah.
But I'm excited.
I think it would be fun.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's going to happen.
I think it'd be interesting,
but I'm so fucking busy right now between the UFC on the road comedy and writing
and doing this podcast and all these different things that I love.
I love doing all of them.
So it's,
it's hard to think about doing something else.
I do think though,
if you do do it,
it would help all your other things and make all your other things better.
It feels like it,
you know,
it was all of our babies,
that show was all of our babies,
but
the,
you know,
but to me it was like I was there for every fucking one of them.
Yeah.
I mean there was,
there's 148 episodes.
I was there,
the whole thing.
So I feel like for me it almost feels like,
man,
if someone else is doing it,
it's like someone is wearing my condom.
Yeah.
It's not like someone's fucking my wife,
but it's like someone is wearing right.
And My condo,
like you're doing it your way I guess.
But Hey man,
what are you doing with that?
I would feel real weird.
But now it makes me feel like a super douche bag for doing the man show.
You know?
Because like for Jimmy and Adam,
it's really so great to have someone else do it.
I would have never heard that knows if that came up again and someone said,
would you do the match on now?
And I've never in a million years,
but I do it.
I was delusional.
You were stepping into a machine with that show.
Why don't you,
and you didn't really have room to take it over.
No,
they wouldn't.
They want it to fit like in their model of what it was.
And so whenever you compromise,
you know,
two ideas together,
smash up and it's just,
it's going to suck.
It's going to be mediocre.
And that's what it was.
But we shouldn't have done it in the first place.
But I should've done is contacted them and see if they really had a problem with
it the way we were led to believe.
It's like that.
They don't care.
They're done with it.
Did you ever ask them?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Jimmy Kimmel had some,
some strong words about the producers and how it all went down and he was very
upset with how it went down and he sent me a little letter and left me an email.
So we had a nice little back and forth.
Yeah.
That's the nature of things in general,
man.
They crumble.
They,
the systems fall apart.
The way they had it organized,
it was destined to change and you can't have the two different hosts doing a
comedy show and have it be the same show.
That's not going to be the same shot.
I wonder if they're ever going to release it on DVD or happening.
I hope they don't.
Just one of those things.
I didn't let it go.
Let it out.
Fire.
I apologize.
The Jimmy Kimmel show.
That's cool.
So I was sorry when I did and it was okay.
I just got greedy.
Like the idea of being able to do two TV shows at the same time.
It's like that's ridiculous.
Can I actually do that?
You know?
And then the idea of also being able to do something comedy wise.
Cause then it was a little weird doing for your factor cause it was like God,
you know,
a huge percent of the people don't even know I'm a comedian.
Yeah.
When I'd say it'd be appearing somewhere,
they'd be like,
what's he doing?
Or your factor guy?
Yeah.
What's he doing?
And get a feed somebody.
Yeah.
Well boy,
where's the wombs?
Yeah,
we won't
hear that way,
man.
Man,
you got to get my boy on worse.
The Joe Rogan experience.
That's a whole in there.
Hold that,
hold that.
Got Something and then,
okay.
Bye.
All right.
You're all right.
Don't worry.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I say stop.
Stop,
stop,
stop.
Please,
please stop.
Please help me.
I know I'm not.